just so much except around the filming
Kim being a part of it what was it like
to have her on set and be around someone
so iconic that was just amazing she's
just like I've admired her work for so
long and to have her on set was pretty
pretty cool and then to work with her
and then the scenes we had together were
so funny and just such a funny dynamic I
never really whenever i imagine working
with her in my life um I never thought
it would be in this specific
circumstance but um so it's really great
does this mean your mom might see this
one cuz games in it oh I don't think so
she's still not going to see it know my
family um no they would be so
uncomfortable and that's not and that's
not really an enjoyable part of watching
a movie I can imagine yeah what about
yourself in terms of comfort I mean
obviously our life is change
substantially since from the first
installment I would imagine you know
something like you know reading
yesterday and just some things like
there's a lot of coverage over you
deleting your Instagram pictures oh and
I was wondering is that kind of coverage
and that kind of attention that you get
now in a constant basis has that started
to feel normal yet no no no no not at
all
will it ever do you think it's something
you invite or something that's difficult
I don't think that I will I personally
will ever get used to um like masses of
people having opinions of my actions or
knowing what I'm doing I don't think
that'll ever become the new like a
normal thing for me but yeah I don't
know it's very bizarre
uh-huh I don't know okay
that's well said I get it as well I
can't imagine maybe there yeah it's a
tricky thing I guess I guess I'll become
more accustomed to like that happening
more but I don't think I'll ever not
care you know but it's a weird thing to
be to be so public